Today I want to talk
about the importance
of the basic education
system, and the theme
is going to be that it's a
necessary, but not sufficient
strategy, for education
for the future.
We're all familiar with
the basic education model.
We start in kindergarten
and go through grade school
through high school.
Hopefully go on to a two-
or a four-year college
and maybe even to
graduate school.
Then we enter the labor force
and we start our working career
after we complete our education.
Well that model no longer works.
Today, we have to think
about lifelong learning
because technologies
are changing,
the job market is changing
in unpredictable ways,
and new ways of
working are going
to continue to come along.
They're going to require
us to refresh our skills.
As this graph shows,
the evidence is clear.
High school dropouts
are really doomed
to a lifetime of poverty wages.
On average they earn
about $24,000 a year.
High school graduates get
to about $34,000 a year,
and college graduates
get to about $55,000
a year average income.
So the key lesson of this
graph is, by all means,
every one must
finish high school
and hopefully go beyond that.
But you could say the same thing
for high school graduation.
College still pays off.
This graph shows the
difference in median earnings
of high school and
college graduates,
and you'll see that it's
been growing over time.
That's both for
men and for women.
The gap between high school
and the college degree earnings
has grown, and so there's
increasing returns to college
even given the increased
cost of college.
This graph shows that adjusting
for the increased cost,
that gap is still growing
and the increase in returns
to college, particularly
since around 1980,
have been growing by
very, very large numbers.
And so the message here is
that, yes, college is expensive,
but we've got to be careful
not to underestimate its value.
At the same time, it's
important to recognize
that there's wide variation
in the earnings of college
graduates.
So it's very important to
be careful to choose when,
where, and what kind
of organization,
what kind of
institution you choose
to get your education at.
Ending your education and
then entering the workforce
was a model that
worked in the past,
but it's not going to
work in the future.
So let's look more
carefully at how
we're going to move through
a model of lifelong learning
in the future.